ce journaliste se met à filmer avec son
téléphone il se passe quelque chose à
cognac la petite chanson pop à la radio
tranche avec l'ambiance de guerre
la ville entière va devenir un vaste
champ de bataille a commencé avec un
déploiement de police autour d'une
maison à l'intérieur il y à ovide you
guzmán le jeune homme de 29 ans a repris
les affaires de son père el chapo
legrand narcotrafiquants condamné à la
perpétuité cet été aux états unis mais
les sicario arrivent de partout pour
protéger leurs patrons et comme le
montrent ces images
ils sont beaucoup mieux armé que la
police au milieu des crépitement de
mitraillettes un bruit sourd de
roquettes la ville est littéralement à
feu et à sang les habitants cours pour
éviter les balles perdues se terrent
dans les supermarchés ou utilisent leur
voiture comme bouclier papa est ce qu'on
peut se relever non ma chérie il faut
rester au sol
mais pourquoi parce que l'assaut du
cartel de sinaloa contre les forces de
l'ordre n'est pas terminée mais la
police ne va pas résister longtemps
devant la puissance de feu des narcos
ils ont dû abandonner
comme l'a expliqué le président ce matin
on ne peut plus combattre le feu par le
feu comme on le faisait avant dé vie
était en jeu et nous devions les
protéger
sauf que dans leur retraite les
policiers abandonne aussi leurs prises
aux vidéos guzmán libéré la méthode du
nouveau président se retrouve sous le
feu des critiques gouvernement qui a
montré qu'il avait des nerfs
une opération de police improvisé qui se
termine avec au moins sept morts dans
l'une des batailles les plus violentes
de ces dernières années au mexique
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal